Bitte schön.
Okay.
Guten Tag.
Dr. Erbilen ist mein Name.
Ich bin zuständige Ärztin heute Prüsi.
Ich möchte mit Ihnen eine anamnesische Gespräche durchführen.
Und kurzum Ablauf möchte ich ein paar Personen bezogene Fragen stellen.
Dann können wir über Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden besprechen.
Alles in Ordnung für Sie?
Wie heißen Sie bitte?
Ich heiße Gerda Mais.
Können Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen buchstabieren?
Ja, der Vorname ist Gerda G-E-R-D-A.
Und der Familienname ist Mais M-A-I-S.
Okay. Das ist ein männlicher Name.
Eine Frau.
Frau Mais, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 56 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 12.07.1967.
67, ja.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,68 Meter.
68, okay.
Wie viel wiegen Sie zur Zeit?
72 kg.
Vielen Dank für deine Informationen, Frau Mais.
Was führt Sie zu uns?
Was für Beschwerden haben Sie?
Ich habe seit einer Woche solche Husten.
Das wird immer schlimmer.
Ich habe solche Schmerzen.
Wie tut die Brust weh, wenn ich huste?
Ich habe jetzt gemerkt, ich habe Fieber.
Ich hatte Schüttelfrost heute Nacht.
Zwischendurch war ich schweiß über Ström.
Ich habe keine Lust, weil der Hitze kein Wunder.
Aber dann habe ich wieder gefroren.
Ich habe keine Luft bekommen.
Auch jetzt habe ich das Gefühl,
dass ich kaum Luft bekomme.
Ich fühle mich ganz schwach und schlecht.
Ich verstehe Sie.
Sie haben gesagt,
seit einer Woche haben Sie Husten.
Aber heute bekommen Sie Atemnot.
Das wurde immer schlimmer.
Seit 2-3 Tagen habe ich diese Brustschmerzen.
Ich habe gemerkt, ich habe Fieber.
Ich habe auch schwere Luft bekommen.
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich habe keine Lust.
Ich habe keine Lust.
Ich habe auch schwere Luft bekommen.
Das Gefühl, mein Herz springt mir raus.
Ich fühle mich ganz schlapp.
Ich erkenne mich selber gar nicht wieder.
Ich verstehe.
Sie haben gesagt,
Sie haben das Fieber gemessen.
Und seit wann haben Sie Fieber?
Ich habe gemessen gestern Abend.
Weil ich da gemerkt habe,
dass ich so Schüttelfrost habe.
Aber ich habe das schon länger.
Ich habe mich schon die Tage gefühlt.
Gestern Abend war das 39 neun.
39 neun?
Okay.
Ich habe ein paar Tage.
Frau Meiss,
Sie sind geschmackst.
sind nur beim Husten aufgetreten oder auch imada?
Also die sind beim Husten da und auch wenn ich wenn ich ein Atmer habe, habe ich das
Gefühl, dass ich Schmerzen habe und dann atme ich gar nicht so tief, sondern nur so
flach, weil es sonst weh tut.
Okay, Framais, können Sie, ja,
brauchen Sie ein bisschen Sauerstoff zur Seite oder können Sie diese
Beschwerden am Ende des Gespräch aushalten?
Ja, ich habe das jetzt schon den ganzen Tag, also insofern ist es auch egal,
dann können wir auch eben noch die Beschwerden nicht erfahren.
Okay, so, haben Sie etwas dagegen eingenommen,
Frau Meins?
Ja, ich hatte so Hustentropfen zu Hause, die habe ich jetzt die letzten Tage
eingenommen, aber das waren so Kodeintropfen, aber die hatte ich noch von,
was war es ich von früher, aber trotzdem huste ich weiter und habe das Gefühl,
dass es überhaupt nicht besser wird.
Okay, ja, so gibt es Auswurf beim Husten?
Ja, da kommt ein bisschen Schleim raus, aber das ist alles nur so ein bisschen
gelblicher Schleim.
Okay, so, waren Sie deswegen beim anderen Arzt?
Nein, ich bin jetzt gekommen, weil das eben nicht geschockt hat,
dass ich so Fieber habe und dass ich so luftnötig bin, deswegen bin ich schnell hierhergekommen.
Okay, sind die Beschwerden erste Episode oder haben Sie endlich Beschwerden früher gehabt?
Ja, Husten hat man ja immer mal, aber dass ich das so schlimm habe,
das kann ich mich nicht erinnern.
Okay, so, als begleitete Synthomasie haben gesagt,
Herzstraßen und Müdigkeit, ist Ihnen übel?
Nee, so richtig schlecht ist mir nicht.
Manchmal, wenn ich so richtig so eine Husten-Attacke habe,
dann ist das so, dass das fast so ein bisschen zürgt, ja.
Aber ich muss mich nicht übergeben oder so, aber manchmal ist der Husten eben sehr stark.
Okay, so, genau.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit, Frau Meins?
Normalerweise ist er gut, aber jetzt heute und die letzten Tage habe ich nicht viel gegessen.
Ich habe auch gesehen, dass ich jetzt im Laufe der letzten Woche ein gutes Kilo abgenommen habe.
Wie viel Kilo abgenommen?
Etwas mehr als ein Kilo.
Okay.
Haben Sie Auffälligkeiten beim Stuhlgang oder Wasserlassen?
Nein, eigentlich ist das alles ganz normal, wie immer.
Okay. Wie ist Ihr Schlaf?
Haben Sie Probleme mit der Schlafschaft?
Ich kann nicht gut schlafen, aber jetzt die letzten Nächte habe ich wegen des Hutens nicht schlafen können.
Gerade in der Nacht ist es eigentlich besonders unangenehm.
Dann muss ich immer wieder mich aufsetzen und auch ein Stück trinken.
Ich habe immer gedacht, das wird irgendwann mal besser, aber jetzt ist es gar nicht.
Okay.
Ja, jetzt, ich möchte ein paar Fragen über Ihre Vorgeschichte stellen.
Leiden Sie irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen, Frau Meins?
Ich meine, die Zuckerkrankheit?
Ja, man hat vor etwas über zehn Jahren festgestellt, dass ich eine Zuckerkrankheit habe und Diabetes habe.
Und da muss ich mit Formin nehmen und ansonsten habe ich ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck.
Okay.
Die Zuckerkrankheit ist Typ 2, oder?
Ja, also als mögliche oder so, hatte ich das nicht. Nein.
Aber das ist Typ 2, ja.
Erinnern Sie sich an die Dosierung für mit Formin?
Also ich nehme morgens einen Tabletto und ich meine, da steht 1000 raus.
1000, okay.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie hohen Blutdruck haben. Seit wann haben Sie Leidensee an Blutdruck?
Naja, das hat man so ein bisschen eher festgestellt, bevor das mit dem Diabetes rausgekommen ist.
Also vielleicht so 15 Jahre oder so.
Und da nehme ich aber regelmäßig jetzt Rami-Pril, eine morgens und eine Abend.
Und damit geht es mir ganz gut.
Erinnern Sie sich auch an die Dosierung von Rami-Pril?
Ich meine, das ist Rami-Pril 10.
Rami-Pril, Rami-Pril, Rami-Pril, Rami-Pril, Rami-Pril, Rami-Pril, Rami-Pril, Rami-Pril, Rami-Pril, Rami-Pril, Rami-Pril, Rami-Pril, Rami-Pril, Rami-Pril, Rami-Pril.
Okay.
Gibt es noch etwas oder alles?
Nein, das lag mir völlig.
Oh, ja, genau.
Würden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Okay. Wurden Sie schon einmal auch wegen
Suckerkrankheit oder artellellig hypertonie stationär behandelt?
Ja, also ich war wegen des Zuckers war ich jetzt in den letzten Jahren
zweimal kurzfristig stationär, weil das irgendwie ein bisschen durcheinander war,
aber ich weiß nicht, was da los war, aber jetzt in letzter Zeit nicht.
Ja, alles in Ordnung zurzeit, ja?
Ja, ja, total.
Okay, sehr gut. Sind Sie allergisch auf irgendwelche Stoff- oder Medikamente?
Also ist mir nichts bekannt, ich wüsste nicht, dass ich auf irgendwas bisher allergisch reagiere,
aber ich kann eigentlich alles essen und trinken und es ist auch nichts mit Medikamenten irgendwie auffällig.
Okay, ich verstelle Sie haben keine Unverträglichkeiten auch?
Nee, nix.
Okay, alles klar.
So, jetzt ich möchte ein paar Fragen über Ihre Gewohnheit stellen, Frau Meis.
Rauchen Sie?
Nee, also ich habe noch nie geraucht, nein.
Und allein der Gedanke, da muss ich ja schon Husten nach.
Ja, freut mich.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol, Frau Meis?
Also ganz selten mal, wenn sich etwas anbietet, wenn es einen Fest gibt,
oder wenn es etwas ein gemütlicher Abend oder beim Grillen, dass man mal ein Bier trinkt oder so,
aber ich trink nicht jeden Tag Alkohol.
Okay.
Ja, die nächste Frage ist ein bisschen anders.
So, haben Sie Erfahrung mit Drogen?
Mit Drogen? Nein, da habe ich keine Erfahrung.
Ja, okay.
Frau Meis, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe zwei Kinder, aber die sind schon groß, die sind schon nicht mehr bei uns im Haus.
Okay, sind Sie gesund?
Die Kinder sind gesund, ja.
Sehr gut.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich arbeite beim Finanzamt.
Haben Sie Stress auf der Arbeit?
Ja, hin und wieder habe ich schon mal Stress,
aber eigentlich ist das ein sehr interessanter Job.
Ja, sehr gut.
Wie ist Ihr Impfstatus?
Ich bin natürlich gegen Corona geimpft, weil wir ja auch hin und wieder Publikumsverkehr haben
und überhaupt klar gegen Corona bin ich komplett geimpft
und sonst glaube ich auch gegen alles, was passieren kann.
Okay, sehr gut.
War denn Sie in den letzten sechs Monaten im Ausland?
Oh, ich muss sich überlegen, ja, wir waren einmal in den Niederlanden,
also hier direkt in der Nachbarschaft, und dann war ich auch einmal in Österreich,
aber sonst in exotischen Ländern war ich nicht.
Okay, okay.
Frau Meins, gibt es wichtige Vorerkrankungen in Ihrer Familie,
von denen ich wissen sollte?
Ja, mein Vater hat genau wie ich einen hohen Blutdruck,
das habe ich von ihm geerbt,
und meine Mutter ist früh gestorben, also früh,
die hat halt im Alter Großkrebs bekommen
und eben so eine Variante, die nicht gut zu behandeln war
und die ist da dran gestorben.
Es tut mir sehr leid, Frau Meins.
Wie alt war sie, als sie verstorben ist?
Ja, da war sie Mitte 70.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Frau Meins, das ist nicht direkt unsere Beschwerden zusammenhangt,
aber machen Sie auch die Brustkontrolle?
Was mache ich?
Brustkontrolle.
Ja, ich gehe regelmäßig zur Krebsforsorge, ja klar.
Das ist sehr wichtig, das freut mich auch.
Haben Sie Geschwester?
Nein, ich habe keine Geschwester.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Jetzt, ich möchte eine kleine Zusammenfassung machen,
wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen oder vergessen oder falsch verstehen,
korrigieren Sie mich.
Ja, natürlich.
Sie haben seit einer Woche Hüsten und Brustschmerzen,
besonders beim Hüsten stark.
Sie haben auch Fieber, Nachtschweiß und Schüttelfrost.
Sie haben auch Luftnot,
sie haben gegen Hüsten Tropfen eingenommen.
Es gibt auch Auswurf,
Schleimge und Derbleher,
Auswurf.
Ich habe nicht gefragt, wie stark sind die Brustschmerzen?
Können Sie beurteilen auf eine Schmerzskala,
wobei ein sehr leicht unerträgliches Schmerz entspricht?
Unerträglich sind die nicht, das kann ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Aber es ist schon so, dass ich eine Schonhaltung mache,
dass ich versuche, nicht so tief einzuaten.
Ich würde vielleicht sagen,
dass die bei sechs sind, die Schmerzen,
zwischen fünf und sechs.
Es ist schon so, dass es mich quält.
Okay, ich möchte noch eine Frage.
Ich habe nicht eigentlich gewundert, es ist ja so sommerlich warm.
Da denkt man ja eigentlich nicht, dass man so eine Erkältung hat.
Auf der anderen Seite ist es natürlich schon so,
dass Klimaanlagen laufen.
Dann ist man verschwitzt und wird wieder kalt.
Ich habe gedacht, ein Husten ist jetzt nicht so erstaunlich.
Aber es wird eben sogar nicht besser.
Ich verstehe so.
Aber du schnupfen oder so, das habe ich jetzt nicht.
Okay, okay.
Okay, so gibt es jemanden in ihrer Umgebung,
die endlich besparen haben?
Ich nicht, sonst sind alle gesund eigentlich.
Okay, ja.
Ich bin mit dem Gespräch durch.
Möchten Sie, haben Sie Fragen?
Ja, die Frage ist natürlich, was kann man jetzt dagegen machen?
Wie lange wird das dauern, bis es mir wieder besser geht?
Und was steckt überhaupt dahinter?
Frau Meus, ich werde Sie zuerst körperlich untersuchen.
Danach nehme ich Blut ein.
Und ich werde auch Brustrundgenaufnahme veranlassen.
Ich werde auch eine EKG verschreiben zur Sicherheit.
Und dann, sobald alle Ergebnisse vorliegen,
können wir noch einmal über Ihre Diagnose und Therapiemöglichkeiten
zusammen besprechen.
Ja, das kann ich gut verstehen.
Aber muss ich denn jetzt im Krankenhaus bleiben?
Das hängt von, ja, zumindest, bis alle Ergebnisse da sind,
müssen Sie bei uns bleiben.
Aber je nach Ergebnisse werden wir auch noch mal besprechen,
ob Sie hier bleiben oder nach Hause zu gehen können.
Okay, gut.
Ich komme gleich, Sie können Warteraum gehen.
Gut, dann gehe ich jetzt zum Krankenhaus.
Danke schön.
Ich habe eine Frage vielleicht.
Wenn merken Sie die Schwelge an Ihrem Weine?
Ist mir nicht aufgescheinend.
Müssten Sie in der Nacht aufstechen, um auf die Toilette zu gehen?
Normalerweise nicht.
Ich habe nur, wenn ich nachts aufwachen und huste,
dann habe ich auch so einen Druck.
Und dann muss ich auch zwischendurch auf die Toilette gehen.
Aber normalerweise muss ich das eigentlich eher nicht.
Okay, bemerken Sie etwas in den Halb zwei Wochen,
dass die Ihrer Beschwerden ausgelöst haben?
Ausgelöst?
Ja, ich habe mir gedacht, dass ich irgendwie kalt geworden bin.
Und deswegen den Husten bekommen habe.
Es war ja so warm, dass ich vielleicht durch Klimaanlage
oder so irgendwie kalt geworden bin.
Und dann, dass dann der Husten mich so angeflogen hat.
Okay, danke.
Und dann hat jemand nach dem Appetit,
hat die Kollegin aber schon gefragt,
dass es mir normalerweise eigentlich gut schmeckt,
dass ich aber im Augenblick keinen Appetit habe,
dass ich das normalerweise auch beim Essen ziemlich fusten muss.
Ja, ich denke, alle Fragen gestellt.
Eine Frage.
Ja.
Waren Sie schon wegen dieser Beschwerden beim Ihren Haushalts?
Nein, da war ich noch nicht.
Ich bin jetzt nur gekommen wegen der Luftnot
und deswegen bin ich jetzt in die Klinik direkt gekommen,
weil ich Angst hatte.
Und diese Frage schon gestellt?
Ja, genau.
Können wir als Erzatsgeschef reanfangen?
Ja, auf meiner Seite.
Von mir aus auch, natürlich.
Ich verstehe jetzt.
Guten Abend, Frau Obererztin.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin gerade gesehen,
die ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Hätten Sie Zeit dafür?
Ja, natürlich.
Wie lange haben Sie denn gesehen?
Danke schön.
Es geht um Gerda Mais.
Sie ist 56 Jahre alt.
Sie ist 1,68 m groß.
Und 72 kg schwer.
Frau Gerda Mais hat sich heute bei uns
wegen seit einer Woche bestehende,
starke Hüsten und Brustschmerzen vorgestellt.
Sind die Schmerzen schon seit der ganzen Woche da?
Nein.
Nein, aber im Verlauf der Zeit
hätten sich die Schmerzen und Hüsten schlimmer geworden sein.
Genau.
Und außerhalb berichtete sie,
dass in den letzten Tagen Fieber,
Nachtschweiß und Schütterlbrust
haben geholfen.
Und gegen die Hüsten
haben sie eine Kodin-Tropfen eingenommen.
Aber die Tropfen haben sie nicht geholfen.
Und zusätzlich teilte sie mit
auch sie mit Hüsten schleimige,
gelbliche Auswurf gehabt.
Und als weitere Begleitzentrum
klackte sie über Tatjukardi und Fatihik.
Haben sie denn schon ein EKG gemacht?
Nein, ich mache das nach der Vorstellung.
Die vegetative Anamnese sei unabfällig,
bis auf beschwerde Bedingte in Appetenz,
um die Züge und die Gewicht zu verhören.
Von einer Kilogramm bis einer Woche.
Und dafür haben sie die Diabetes Meletus,
die Zwei-Tübzeit-Zenjahr,
Arterielle-Hypertonie seit den Fünften Jahren.
Es wurde bei der Patientin eine Appendectomie als Kindheit durchgeführt werden.
In der Kindheit?
In der Kindheit.
Und zusätzlich wurde sie in den letzten Jahr zweimal wegen der Blutzucker durch einander stationär behandelt.
Es sind keine Allergieunverträglichkeiten bei ihr bekannt.
Sie ist, sie sei nicht Raucherin.
Sie trink selten Bier.
Die Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Sie ist verheiratet und habe zwei gesunde Kinder.
Sie ist Angestellter beim Finanzamt.
Sie habe nicht so viel Stress.
Sie war in den letzten sechs Monaten in Niederland und Österreich.
Sie ist ein sehr Kind.
Alle an einem nestischen Angabe dueten am Erhästen auf eine Pneumonie hin.
Sie hat eine Pulmoner-Embulie mit dem Infarktus im Betracht.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, werde ich die Patientin körperlich untersuchen.
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Ich werde als Inspektion auf Zionose abhören.
Ich höre die Lunge ab.
Ich werde die Lunge aufhören.
Ich werde auch die Perkussion aufhören.
Danach werde ich die Blut abnehmen.
Beim Labor bestimme ich die Blutbilder, CRP, BSG, Troponin, CK, CKMB.
Ich werde auch die Antibiotter und die Kultur auswirken.
Was würde man heute noch machen?
Ein Corona-Test.
Dann werde ich auch rund ein Aufnahme veranlassen.
Gegebenenfalls werde ich auch vielleicht ein CT veranlassen.
Gut.
Wenn Sie Ihre Diagnose bestätigen, wäre das die Therapieoption?
Ich werde diese Patientin stationär aufnehmen.
Sie haben der Betis und arterielle Hypertone.
Ihr Zustand ist nicht so gut.
Dann werde ich ausreichende Politik zufurcht geben.
Und Schlammlösende Antidetheziven.
Antibiotikum und Antibiotikum.
Auf das Antibiogramm warten wir vom Labor.
Man würde mit der Breitband anfangen.
Dann halten Sie mich auf dem Lausenden, was mit der Patientin ist.
Wie Ihr weiterer Zustand ist.
Ich habe eigentlich nur eine Beziehung.
Ich habe zwei Kleinigkeiten.
Herr Gündis, die Patientin muss sofort einmal untergegut werden.
Sie haben einen Hinsichtlich-Vital-Parameter.
Sie haben einen EKG-Sauerstoff-Sättigung.
Sie haben gesagt, es ist sehr hoch.
Das ist der einzige Schönheitsfehler, der mir jetzt aufhält.
Was mir aufgefallen ist beim Sprechen.
Das merken Sie wahrscheinlich gar nicht.
Sie machen ganz oft so eine Verlege.
Das ist in der Häufung.
Wenn Sie das noch mal anhören, wird Ihnen das auffallen.
Das ist schwer, sich das abzugewöhnen.
Ich würde das nicht als Katastrophe ansehen.
Das ist sicherlich etwas, wo Sie versuchen müssen, daran zu arbeiten.
Es zeigt eine gewisse Suche.
Wir Deutschen machen das auch, obwohl es unsere Muttersprache ist.
Wir machen auch solche Füsse.
Ich mache das selber auch.
Aber vielleicht nicht ganz so oft wie Sie.
Das müssten Sie versuchen, ein bisschen zu glätten.
Vielleicht hilft es, wenn Sie sich eine Formulierung vorgeben.
Das ist eine Formulierung, die Sie sagen.
In der Familie in einem Nese wurde berichtet von einer Hypatonie
auf Seiten des Vaters.
Und einer Großzirpserkrankung seitens der Mutter.
Die Mutter ist auch an den Mama-Katzelnungen gestorben.
Und nicht, während man darüber nachdenkt, noch formulieren muss.
Dann sparen Sie sich diese Zeit und können auf ein fertig formuliertes Satz zurückgreifen.
Das würde vielleicht so ein bisschen Entlastung bringen.
Markanterweise war es beim Fragestellen viel weniger.
Aber nachher beim Bericht war es mehr.
Ansonsten habe ich Sie als sehr souverän erlebt.
Als sehr straight, was die Fragestellungen angeht.
Auch Ihre Einleitung sehr schön.
Wir machen jetzt erst die persönlichen Daten.
Und nachher sprechen wir über Ihre Beschwerden.
Sie haben konsequent weitergefragt.
Wenn die Patientin etwas gesagt hat, sind Sie darauf eingegangen.
Sie haben Sie auch immer schön mit Namen angesprochen.
Das ist natürlich auch immer so etwas, was sehr, sehr positiv ist.
Und was Sie auch sehr elegant gemacht haben.
Zum Schluss ist Ihnen auch aufgefallen,
dass Sie nicht nach der Schmerzintensität gebracht haben.
Und das haben Sie dann noch mal so eben nachgeschoben.
Es war sehr unauffällig und sehr dezent.
Super gemacht.
Also wie gesagt, der Anamnese-Teil wirklich sehr schön.
Und dann im Bericht, das ist immer so, das wissen alle.
Der Bericht ist ein schwerer Teil.
Da sind mir noch zwei winzige Sachen.
Sie nimmt eine Codientropfen.
Nein, kein Artikel davor.
Weder einen unbestimmten noch einen bestimmten.
Sie hat dagegen Codientropfen eingenommen.
Und auch genauso Drohrenkonsum wurde verneint.
Auch da kein Artikel.
Ich habe das schon oft gesagt.
Viele Kollegen tragen in der Anamnese.
Das haben Sie nicht gemacht.
Haben Sie Kontakt zu den Drogen?
Nein, das fragt man.
Haben Sie oder hatten Sie jemals Kontakt zu Drogen?
Und dann eben Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Wenn überhaupt der Drogenkonsum.
Und nicht die.
Aber am besten eben Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Langt völlig.
Weil das so allgemeine Sachen sind.
Ansonsten, wie gesagt, sprachlich habe ich das Gefühl,
dass Sie sehr, sehr souverän unterwegs sind.
Und das ist so eine, glaubt, Sie es mit dem,
das ist nur so eine Angewohnheit.
Versuchen Sie da noch ein ganz bisschen zu üben.
Vielleicht tatsächlich auch selber mal aufnehmen,
aber das, was Sie sagen, wenn Sie frei etwas sprechen,
um das nochmal zu kontrollieren, ob Sie, wenn Sie gut darauf achten,
das schaffen, ein bisschen auszublenden.
Ja, das ist mein Problem.
Ansonsten können Sie, glaube ich, sehr zufrieden sein.
Ja, und Ihre Grüfung gelassen entgegen gucken.
Ja, gut.
Ja, auch das ist das, was Sie sagen,
auch das ist das.
Ich habe eine,
ich lege eine kleine значит.
Wir haben uns auf jeden Fall,
Perfekt, Ideen, Niktür und so weiter und verlaufen, lethal, verlaufen das.
Mama kass noch. Ja, ja, ja. Stimmt, ja. Das ist noch ein guter Hinweis.
Auswurf, Tutzi und so weiter.
Sputunkultur hat sie gesagt?
Ja, wir haben gesagt Sputunkultur, aber Sputum nicht gesagt. Auswurf.
Ja, genau. Ja, ja, gut.
Das ist noch mal ein sehr guter konkreter Hinweis, ja, viel da.
Okay. Ja, danke schön.
Gut, soll sie uns am Dienstag wiedersehen? Ja.
Ja. Okay.